Nick bucks yeah what's up cat welcome
man thank you brother representing
Harlem yes sir uh for people who don't
know who you are man kind of give me
like a little background of like
obviously you're from Harlem but just
kind of how long you've been rapping and
kind of you know you've obviously been
killing it I told you you had one of my
favorite albums uh it was like early
2021 your album drive right yeah I think
I dropped it like right after was it
called I don't know if it was quarantino
right after
might be right after yeah but nah man
give everybody kind of a rundown man uh
just kind of your history books East
Harlem you know what I mean young spit
up you know one of the hardest from my
size
um you know just real story real
authentic authentic music you know I
mean you know I [ __ ] with the people
yeah I've been to uh East Harlem once
yeah no twice I got off on the train at
the wrong stop oh yeah I was in Harlem
and then I got off early or I got off at
the wrong stop to go see a girl like I
don't know 10 years ago so shout out to
Harlem and then I was out there uh shout
out to Bodega bands oh my God yup El
Barrio for sure he's definitely an East
Harlem representative yeah yeah yeah I
go hard for that my fourth to cut you
over but I go hard for the east side
because you know when people think about
Harlem they think about you know one
area you know like of course dip said
you know 48th Linux but it's bigger than
that the East Harlem is like our own
little lane you know what I'm saying
right and it's like heavily like Latin
Community as well too right no it's
diverse it's diverse okay like each
other is wherever you got Jamaicans you
got African-American you got Puerto
Rican you got Dominican right Mexican
you got we real diverse but we small but
you know we real diverse did you feel
like um because you know with the the
rent prices in Manhattan are so crazy
it's like insane sometimes I just get
bored and go on Zillow and just look at
apartments in New York just to see and
I'm like [ __ ] has there been like a lot
of gentrification in Harlem because it
feels like Harlem's still kind of like
an extension of Manhattan but it's
probably a lot more affordable a lot of
people been moving in in that area and
[ __ ] no it is it is you know we got um
it's moles being built you know all kind
of things so you know when things like
that come into the community it gentrify
it you know I mean it makes things more
expensive 100 so like is it becoming
like a lot like least affordable to stay
in your own hood now um yeah they got
they got these new buildings they got a
lot of new buildings being made you know
like
um with a lot of amenities and stuff
like that so you know those are very
expensive yeah I see it changing